lo primero que hay que tomar en cuenta
es que el presidente de los eeuu no se
elige por elección popular
eso se elige en función de los estados
así que trump tiene posibilidades de
triunfo porque si él logrará retener los
estados del midwest que son los estados
de wisconsin de michigan y ohio si
logrará retener pensilvania y florida
virginia pues definitivamente estaría
quedándose cuatro años más en la casa
blanca ahora teniendo en cuenta las
declaraciones del vicepresidente pensé
donde afirma que los estadounidenses
deben elegir entre la ley la orden que
promete el presidente de nuestro amo y
la anarquía de joe biden porque los
republicanos irán a partido demócrata de
socialistas y anarquistas
bueno el discurso de ley orden es un
discurso viejo ese es el mismo discurso
que utilizo richard nixon en la campaña
presidencial de 1968 en contra del
partido demócrata de lyndon johnson y
jim webb con free funcionó en 1968 y
trompe está apostando a esa misma a ese
mismo discurso a esa misma actitud yo
creo que en 2020 es totalmente distinto
en 1968 y recta por ver si ese discurso
l surtirá efecto a trump en este momento
las encuestas en los eeuu indican lo
contrario
qué podemos esperar esta noche el último
día de esta convención republicana
cuando hable el presidente donald trump
que podemos además esperar en su
discurso luego de todo esto que está
pasando en el país con la pandemia y con
las protestas por la muerte de blake por
la muerte no por por el disparo de blake
pero con toda certeza trump va a ahondar
más en el discurso de ley y orden a
crear los contrastes con joe biden
me parece que tromba a cara
fuertemente hay un país en fíjense que
ayer y la noche antes de ayer es decir
la segunda y la tercera noche han sido
relativamente positivas no ha habido
tanto ataque visceral como la primera
noche y yo entiendo que esta noche que
es la culminación del partido
republicano le van a tirar con la
artillería pesada hay un vaivén y una
vez concluya la convención pues entonces
todos los caminos conducen a los tres
debates presidenciales que comienzan en
septiembre hasta octubre entonces la
elección sería el 3 de noviembre así que
estamos comenzando la recta final de
este proceso presidencial